every month the what's inside page gives
wired readers a look at the ingredients
that make up everyday products but the
item also presents a monthly challenge
to photographers how do you make a
mundane material like fast drying cement
look interesting
at his studio in woodstock new york
photographer dan forbes went through 50
bags of quikrete to shoot the fast
setting concrete mix featured in this
month's what's inside
the road to the final image was a rocky
one to maintain the liquid mixture's
consistency water had to be added every
12 minutes
forbes tested various setups including
dropping a bag of dry quikrete into a
wooden pit of wet quikrete to create a
splashing effect
building a mold for the solid cube also
took some thinking outside the box
but the trickiest part was capturing the
wet concrete before it dried forbes
raced against the clock to get
everything in just the right place
before each shot
you